[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's peter king the must-read column
football morning in america also working
for nbc sports visited the vikings the
buccaneers got to speak with tom brady
went to the jags camp spoke with urban
meyer and uh the saints situation their
quarterback situation there and uh he
was at the steelers as well the
peripatetic peter king back on the
program pete good to have you back uh if
you look at the rookie quarterback
situation that is
legitimate like the real
story here whether it's the bears or
it's the niners uh which one stands out
the most that you think we're going to
be talking about during the regular
season not just we overhyped the
preseason
i mean i think both those situations are
going to be talked about a lot dan uh
and
you know it's getting harder and harder
for a coach like matt maggie or kyle
shanahan to try to do the right thing
for a rookie quarterback picked in the
first half of the first round
you know uh it's you know the other day
i thought that
you know in chicago it just it was an
exclamation point
on
how
uh and and again this is this an
exaggeration okay but how it's almost
like mob rule is trying to pick the
quarterback you know in chicago
and it doesn't matter if justin fields
is ready i have no idea if he's ready or
not no one knows
but uh you know damn it we picked the
guy 10th or 11th overall whatever it was
and damn it he's gonna play we picked we
we traded
three ones to go get uh
trey lance dammit in san francisco you
know he should play instead of garoppolo
i mean it's like i wrote last week
all you have to do is look at all the
guys who didn't play or barely played as
rookies tom brady patrick mahomes drew
brees carson palmer i mean all you have
to do is look at all those guys and say
man is it the idea to get a quarterback
for the next 15 years
not to rush him in
maybe before he's ready um look
it's possible
that patrick mahomes would have played
great as a rookie but you know alex
smith quarterbacked him to the playoffs
probably his best year in the nfl
and and so you know and now andy reid
looks like a genius i just would say to
fans we just relax
you know a guy doesn't have to play this
year he doesn't have to do what is best
for a player long term i'm not saying
you absolutely should sit him i'm just
saying that it's ridiculous that you
know that people in the in the second
preseason game are booing the crap out
of andy dalton i mean come on just stop
yeah i'm wondering but we it's like the
jets the jets had a great weekend
not many teams go we had a great weekend
and it's august the jets are desperate
for anything and zach wilson throwing a
couple of touchdown passes um that's a
great weekend for them but it feels like
their philosophy is we drafted you we're
playing you there's no reason to to have
you ease your way into the lineup what
do you what is your philosophy on that
that playing a rookie quarterback or
letting him kind of ease into the lineup
well
if the jets had andy dalton or jimmy
garoppolo i doubt that zach wilson would
be the absolute no doubt starter
look at the backups
for the jets
james morgan
mike white josh johnson those guys are
not household names in their own
household
and so you know
you know look i think joe douglas is a
really good general manager i like him
and i think he's doing a good job
building up this team
but
i think it's a terrible mistake to not
have a backup quarterback you know who's
a veteran and i'm sure that they made a
call about nick foles i mean nick
foale's going to languish as the number
three in chicago unless somebody makes
an offer that ryan pace thinks is good
enough
you know that that he would take
uh but but again
it's a totally different situation who
else is gonna play you're gonna trot out
last year's fourth round pick james
morgan to to start the opener and to
go into carolina and play and that's why
it's almost been preordained from day
one that zach wilson was going to play
yeah i just worry the
rookie quarterback gets into bad habits
or you know sam darnold was seeing
ghosts like you get into a situation
where
you david carr is the quarterback that
always comes to mind i don't think any
quarterback in his first three years got
sacked more than david carr did and i
think that your confidence level gets
shot um you know you get into bad habits
there that would be my concern with zach
wilson the expectation level is higher
than than on any other quarterback even
even uh trevor lawrence like you know
it's new york it's the jets they expect
greatness out of there and that's why i
thought can you get nick foles what's he
going to cost you if you get him yeah or
andy dalton you know maybe that's the
route that they take out of this group
of quarterbacks
which one plays in a playoff game first
uh
trey lance
just because he he's in my opinion of
all the rookie quarterbacks who are
going to play fairly early whether it be
year one or two
um trey lance is on the best team yeah
that's i i mean you know
the the niners got
and again look time will tell if trey
lance is good
trading two future ones for them plus
using that pick on them that's a huge
investment but
i think they can afford to do that
because of
guys like fred warner and bosa
and a good receiving core i i just think
right now they are built
to
rise
uh with a young quarterback to maybe
take some aches and pains with them but
they're a really really good team i
think they're
easily a top 10 team in the league right
now and so i i always look for what
quarterback goes to the best team and he
did
he's peter king football morning in
america the column is out now and um you
spent some time with tom brady brady has
talked about he's gonna know
if he's not playing at a certain level
then it's time to retire but
is he going to know or will somebody
tell him that he's not playing at the
level that he needs to or should be
i mean you never know about something
like that
i'm i didn't cover
wayne gretzky or michael jordan so i
don't know what happened at the end with
them
uh but the fact is you know as i said
today
you know brady is
1593 days older than the next oldest
player in football
and last year
he threw for more touchdowns than
patrick mahomes more yards than aaron
rodgers and he won the super bowl by 22
points
so i mean that's why in my opinion you
talked to him i talked to him he didn't
say anything yeah i'm playing x number
more years he's smart he's just taking
it ear to ear
and he says i'll know so
who knows whether it's him
or whether it's tampa or some other team
that tells him that's it
i think he's on his last team
but i don't know that i don't see how
anybody can know that right now
what uh what did you come away from your
conversation with urban meyer if i'm a
jags fan
how confident should i feel
um
you know i think what urban meyer is
trying to do
he stood in front of his team dan at the
start of the season he said listen
you can call me 24 7. i'm here to help
you your coaches are here to help you
in one day
josh allen the pass rusher
called them from a hospital after just
having a baby and said
they're telling us that my wife has to
take this certain formula all we want to
do is breastfeed the baby baby had some
jaundice hospital said you need to do
have this formula whatever it was so he
didn't know who to call he called urban
meyer and urban meyer fixed it and and i
wrote about that this morning and the
moral of the story is
urban meyer feels like
he needs
to
be there for his
players as people
so that during games they'll be there
for him and for the franchise
and play without reservation
uh all play you know all for one one for
all that kind of stuff so he's doing his
best to try to build the family aspect
of it
but dan you know what i know
that how can you tell
if a guy is going to be able to take all
the losing that you're going to have to
take in the preseason
already one of his veterans had to come
up to him after the first
game taken by the shoulders kind of
gently shake him and say hey coach it's
an f in pre-season game and so anyway
i guess my whole point about this is
you know it's august 23rd
and
i don't know how he's going to take
losing he says he's going to be okay
he's talked to jimmy johnson about what
one in 15 felt like so he understands
that that's going to happen but
i think he is trying his best to build a
roster of players and coaches who care
for each other so that when times get
tough and they will
they're not going to splinter
when do you make your super bowl pick
uh i don't know a couple of weeks
i i don't know it's
how do you not pick kansas city in tampa
i don't know it's a very lazy pick
but
i don't know dan
you know they both look pretty good and
you know the bills look good too so you
never know but
uh i
i think
peter just froze up he was just about to
drop oh there you go okay yeah you froze
up for a second
we don't know we don't know
what is going to happen with covid that
some team is going to get kind of
screwed by covet at some point this year
so
i think it makes it especially difficult
to pick because how do you know what
that team is you know like a southern
team like tamper bruce aryan said we're
being really
really careful they've already had
multiple people i've heard it's more
than five in their organization test
positive after being vaccinated
so i mean
we are in totally
uncharted territory especially for teams
like in florida in texas in the south
um so those are things that we can't we
just can't know right now
i want to leave you with this the uh the
new uh
trying to uh
police taunting here in the nfl
and i'm wondering let's say
last second hail mary and somebody
knocks the ball down
and then they taunt
after the the you know clock is wound
down zero's up there so it's after the
fact
can you call a penalty for taunting
after a game is over and you give the
offense one more play
it's a great question um
and
i think the answer is yes because they
obviously call it like a a continuation
play but that's a you know we at nbc are
going to have our session with
the nfl and with the officials here
coming up soon i'm going to ask that
question
i think it's a really interesting
question but the whole taunting thing
i really don't view it as as anything
that was anything like a a crisis or a
huge problem in the league i don't get
the point of emphasis about it it just
it feels like they're trying to
make a very very emotional game totally
even keel that's a hard thing to do who
brought this up like where was the
outcome i don't even know i don't know i
i was surprised when i read about it i
did i hadn't heard about it
i don't know and
i think the nfl's got to be careful dan
because there's already
it's already the no fun league
and i just think that if you're trying
to fix something that truly may not be
broken i don't understand why that is
pete great to talk to you again thanks
for joining us
okay hey thank you dan take care that's
peter king football mornings in america
that column is out now